ein neuerlicher lockt auch nicht im
grunde vollkommen unvorstellbar ich kann
das in keiner form nachvollziehen der
erste lok tagen wurde und sogar von
unseren politikern bestätigt war schon
umsonst warum sollten wir jetzt nochmal
einen lock down machen
für uns ist es unglaublich wir hatten
drei monate geschlossen
wir haben die leute die bei uns
motorradlenker lehrgänge gebucht haben
die haben wir alle verschieben müssen
die würden wir jetzt nacharbeiten in den
nächsten wochenenden jetzt wollen wir
wieder zusperren sollen die wieder
anschreiben sollte termine wieder
verschieben wir hätten gerade wieder die
systeme hochgefahren gerade wieder
begonnen unsere angebote der lehrgänge
zu realisieren die wir hier in der
karthalle machen
und jetzt sollen wir wieder alle kunden
vor den kopf stoßen ich kann die
entscheidung in unserer regierung in
keiner form mehr nachvollziehen können
sie dann sagen eigentlich werden ja hier
die abstände ja doch perfekt eingehalten
also den abstand kann man ja wenn man
jetzt so ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt
ja nicht auch dann anhalten denn den
vordermann hintendrauf hört man dem
vordermann hinten drauf führt dass man
locker noch zwei meter weg außerdem ist
es natürlich so dass wir ein hygiene
konzept verfolgen wir arbeiten ja hinter
folien wenden wir sind ja die
mitarbeiter tragen masken wir sind ja
abgesicherter kunde bewegt sich bei uns
immer schon mit sturmhaube und helm und
im lokal mit maske wir haben also keine
partystimmung in dem sinn sondern
motorsport und da hat man wirklich
abstand und keine großen risiken wenn
wir jetzt wieder zusperren müssen weiß
ich nicht ob er jemals wieder aufsperren
könnten jetzt leben wir hier in sie
leben jetzt hier in marktl am inn der
geburtsstadt des papstes grenzregion zu
österreich leben sie auch von den
österreichern wie ist das kommen die
über die grenze um ihr kcv unsere
umsätze sind 50 prozent von österreich
weil wir natürlich der grenzregion leben
für uns war diese idee der
grenzschließung in etwa das gleiche wie
wenn man in münchen die stadt in der
hälfte teilen
so geht es eine grenz regierung wenn man
die österreicher nicht mehr überlässt
die unternehmen hüben und drüben sind
abhängig von all diesen kunden und für
uns war das letzte wochenende besonders
intensiv im verlust machen warum am
montag war in österreichischen
nationalfeiertag das war die bucht mit
25 lehrgangsteilnehmer mehreren rennen
für den abend und das haben wir alles
absagen müssen die gelder zurückbezahlen
und wieder die termine verschieben
es ist nicht mehr nachvollziehbar dann
hat dieser staatsminister florian
jammern
endlich den bürgermeistern nachgegeben
und am dienstag dieses reiseverbot
fallen lassen und jetzt soll ab 2011 ein
lockt dann kommen ich kann nicht mehr
nachvollziehen warum herr söder frau
merkel und diese anderen köpfe plötzlich
entscheiden was in deutschland läuft wir
haben ein parlament wir haben 700 neun
abgeordnete sichere orte von denen das
sie nach gewissen entscheiden und dass
sie das wieder an sich nehmen das kann
nicht so weitergehen auch der bayerische
landtag ist in meinen augen absolut
nicht zuverlässig da müssten sich schon
lange menschen melden warum schlafen die
alle in meinen augen blicken die
abgewählt jetzt gibt's einen plan vom
finanzminister olaf scholz dass kleine
betriebe so 75 prozent der ausfälle
zucht bekommen sollen was halten sie
denn davon lohnt sich das bringt es
irgendwas wirklich dass weiterhelfen ich
kann das gar nicht hören dass ein staat
in dem rentner flaschen sammeln müssen
unternehmen geld anbietet dieses geld
das uns der staat anbietet das hat der
staat gar nicht das kommt von uns das
sind unsere steuern kein unternehmer
braucht geld vom staat wir brauchen nur
rahmenbedingungen in denen wir unsere
geschäfte ganz normal betreiben können
haben sie angst um ihr um ihre existenz
ich habe nicht nur angst um meine
existenz ich habe angst um das gesamte
verhältnis in deutschland das ist nicht
mehr normal wie mit uns umgegangen wird
so darf es nicht bleiben so kann es
nicht sein was ist ihr appell an die
politiker was müsste getan werden
endlich zurück zur wahrheit endlich
zugeben dass das alles übertrieben war
und jetzt mal echte experten
untereinander sprechen lassen wir haben
alle ein immunsystem ich verstehe maske
und abstand halten das verstehe ich aber
ich verstehe keinen locker und es hat
keinen sinn den menschen zu sagen bleibt
in ihrer wohnung es kommt der herbst
kommt der winter menschen müssen sich an
der frischen luft bewegen müssen sich
gut ernähren müssen sport und bewegung
haben nur dann hat man eine chance mit
viren die es immer schon gibt auf dieser
welt umzugehen
wie viel geld haben sie denn durch den
ersten lockdown verloren und viele waren
es jetzt auch sie haben gerade
angesprochen durch den österreichischen
nationalfeiertag also kann man das mal
können sie das beziffern wie viel geld
die flöten danke für die frage ich kann
ganz einfach sagen
alleine das was am freitag passiert ist
mit dieser kurzfristigen
fehlentscheidung dass die österreicher
nicht mehr über die grenze fahren dürfen
wir haben daraufhin von freitagmittag
bis montagabend 5000 euro umsatz
verloren
und das ist kein umsatz mit dem wir uns
ein schönes leben machen was ist der
umsatz der die arbeitsplätze aufrecht
hält für uns 35 geschäft mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren